hey everybody you're watching you spot
calm Alexa write and Scott here we just
got to play gears of war force new chord
three-point elbows with a crash course
from the man himself rod fergusson now
that was amazing he helped us out a lot
he guided us through and it was nice
that he was there because horde mode has
gotten way more sophisticated yeah it
feels a lot like a [ __ ] mode from gears
of war two so here's no like kind of
fortifying a position it hasn't become
zombies mode or anything like that like
we're not running through a level you're
still in like a contained area and
trying to hold off wave after wave of
enemy but it has gotten more
sophisticated like you can build all
kinds of new defenses you have clearly
defined roles for each different
character than yea which was that's very
new and very different it really forces
team work because it's somebody's not
doing their job the whole team very
clearly suffers yes and we I think we
saw a little bit of that I know our
Scout had a little bit of a tough time
going and collecting yeah explainable so
so much of it seems to be about energy
collection like you need energy in order
to build new defenses and buy new
weapons and things like that and your
scout character gets double the amount
of energy of anybody else if he picks up
all the energy icons and so that guy's
role really is just run collect energy
don't die everybody else is trying to
support that character
but then there's like the engineer who
gets a deep discount on building
anything so he kind of needs to hang
back and be preparing and building
turrets and things like that there's a
heavy class there's a soldier class and
start I got to play the sniper class
which is a lot of fun like all kinds of
headshot bonuses things like that his
job at least the way I played it was
just kind of followed the scout around
the map and make sure that he didn't die
so again it was really cool seeing how
all of those different roles kind of
slotted together to create a cohesive
team and we had rod as our engineer
which was a double bonus because he knew
exactly what what to buy and what to
build yeah because there's also like
there's a weapons Locker so there's you
know if you go and tie around without
dying during specific grounds will get
an airdrop and that will usually contain
like better weapons and you can hang
onto those and storm and weapon lockers
and use them for later rounds there's
all kinds of new strategies it's just
been added since older gears games a lot
of fun yeah Oh totally I mean again it
kind of captures the joy and the
emergent craziness of horde mode as we
used to know it i mean i actually really
like they've walked back some of the
stuff they added through her gears 3 and
reverted to a much more classic version
but with all this new stuff played on
top i would love to keep playing with
rod he was a great teammate totally good
good team leader way to go rod fergusson
thank you for keeping us alive we
appreciate it yeah and for more news on
pax west and years of war for please see
to gamespot com